if you are thinking of what to do next
in your business and you're stuck and
you've been plateauing at the same space
i was asked to speak to a group of
seven-figure entrepreneurs one of the
questions that i was asked was how to
get unstuck in this situation this is a
multi-location owner who's trying to
scale
and license or franchise their business
and the answer that they gave him is
probably not what you would expect and
may be the reason that you are stuck or
not advancing at the speed with which
you would like all right and so if you
don't know who i am my name is aux mozy
i own acquisition.com it's a portfolio
of companies that is about 85 million a
year and i have nothing to sell you and
so if you are new to mozy nation welcome
and enjoy the video i'll see you in the
other side
joy what are the different exit
strategies you recommend i think i cover
that with anu i think that i think for
most people if you were trying to exit
the gym i would be looking at customer
or employee um and then right now and
this is purpose because right now sba
loans are just a joke to get in like
zero interest so i think that those
would be and you can put a percentage of
seller financing in there to get a
number that you feel comfortable with
and it also doesn't put too much cash
drag on the business
that could be pretty attractive for both
sides
yeah so
kind of
to clarify on the question i guess that
i was wondering like
so we've looked at you know licensing or
franchising or we want to just grow as a
company and then just you know
eventually sell it or what and so we
haven't come up with a clear strategy we
thought we wanted to do like a franchise
route until i started to investigate and
realize that it was going to be a huge
headache
but
i guess kind of what are your thoughts
on you know
in the gym industry if you
what are the different avenues you can
take to exit the company and i mean
either keep it or sell it how many
locations do you have right now yeah
uh three working on a fourth are they
all different markets like different
states are they concentrating on market
in central california so we're not we
haven't even entered into like a
metropolitan area yet um i don't know if
you guys are familiar with fresno
california that's probably going to be
our first
uh city quote unquote that we go into uh
we're technically considered like towns
the facilities
do you want to stay in the fitness
industry
yeah i mean i've been doing it for 14
years now and i can't really real
question that was not it's not loaded
that's like kind of top level question
so if you want to stay in the fitness
industry how do i best package the
skills that i have right now for making
money i have a very important question
yeah
how much money do the locations make
this year each location well we profited
what uh a little over a hundred thousand
per
no that was total between the three
uh this but this year we spent quite a
bit of money
we had a bunch of
stuff we were going through without
getting too into it to uh
so
we have probably roughly
50 000 of expenses that we have that we
won't next year yeah the first thing i'm
thinking is if you've proven out the
multiple locations and they're like
as profitable as they can be before you
scale further that's what i would be
thinking just from where i set just
knowing the amount of people that i know
who grow who have multiple locations
grow to like you know say double digit
multiple and then they go licensing or
franchise the most important piece and
this is where everyone fails is they're
just not profitable enough dude they're
not the unit economics suck you know
what i mean um
like i'm gonna i'm gonna do the i'm
gonna do the dave dunham throw punch
even if you do the add back for the 50k
that's the one-time expense if you're
doing 50 000 net per facility
no one's interested in that it might be
like the the nasty medicine but it'll
actually
solve the pain or solve the problem so
if you've got three locations the fact
that you said we're thinking about a
fourth i'm like why on god's green earth
are you thinking about a fourth location
when we're profiting 30 000 per year per
location like that we're like this
shouldn't even be discussion
and the fact that we went from one to
three
with what i would consider poor profit
metrics i wouldn't have advised that
either but we're in that boat and that's
fine right we're here we are
i would bet you dollars to donuts that
if you got rid of two of them and then
focus your attention on one you would
make more money than you have from the
three just straight up and i think you
need to fix the model
like for the mob because like do you
know how many
like and i'm going to be mean with this
and it's not directed to you but it's
more direct to the industry do you like
do you know how many
mom and pop [ __ ] licensing and
franchises there are of three to five
location owners a [ __ ] zillion of
them
and you know how many franchises never
get above 30 locations because once they
open they do the unit economics that
we're talking about right now
most of them
and that's why most of them don't grow
or go anywhere the guy who started it
feels good because he tells his family
and friends that he's a franchise and
then everyone's like oh wow but they're
broke and they don't know anything and
so why would you care about impressing
them and so
if the goal is to make the most money it
feels like you're in a rush that's what
it feels like to me hearing what you
just said
and so i would lean towards and like i
said this is gonna be like the sour
medicine
if you really wanna do this you gotta do
it right and you gotta fix the model and
the like the locations that you have
have to be corporate they got to be the
best [ __ ] gyms out there for someone
to even consider buying into this either
from a licensing perspective or from a
franchising perspective like these guys
should be running on 30 plus margins
with and if you're if we're doing you
know
is it a large group small group right
now we're just doing large groups so we
haven't even introduced the small group
in yet uh
we're
working on you know
our 90 day and all that stuff on the
front end
make sure that
you're in a smaller market which believe
it or not means you should be running on
higher margins
not lower margins
because in the small markets your costs
are low and there's also less
competition the disadvantage of small
markets is that leads
are great in the beginning and then they
suck
that's the that's kind of the trade-off
and so um and if anything your word of
mouth and your retention has to be more
important in a small in a small town
than anything if you like for example if
you said we've got the small town model
down it's like i wouldn't go to fresno
i'd be looking at what other small towns
are there because we have that model
down you go to fresno you're competing
against everyone you know i mean and the
guys you're competing against they're
pulling out 250 400 a year because their
locations are rocking so i think that i
think it's a it's it's a big look
inwards of like
have i wanted to open more locations so
that i could say i own more locations
and is my goal status or is my goal
money it's important you don't have to
answer now but like it's an important
question
if the goal is money then i would look a
hard look at the other two locations and
think about is there one of these that i
can combine into one i can take the eft
throw it into the other one maybe lose
half of it but i get all of it on the
same fixed overhead make more money at
that second location and then look at
that you know when my lease ends at the
other one so i can focus my attention on
making this gym as wildly profitable as
humanly possible
and then until this gym is growing
without me with a team that's
incentivized now i have an asset on the
balance sheet if you have an asset on
your personal net worth balance sheet
that can then be leveraged in a number
of different ways you could sell the
thing you could license the thing you
could do the franchise because now you
have an actual unit itself that
generates profit in in a with a high
return on capital which is what
someone's going to look at from a
franchise perspective a licensing
perspective or from if you crush it you
could own them all
the guy who lives above me um in vegas i
think i've told you guys he owns panda
express he owns them all isn't franchise
[ __ ] he did he did 3.8 billion last year
26 margins got 26 he took 935 million
home in income
that was his income when we asked what
was the secret to success he said do the
same thing for 45 years
you get really [ __ ] good at making
orange chicken
i'm being real with you if it took you
five years
but then you had the best damn gym model
out there and then five years after that
you had 30 locations would that be
enough because like life's long man
and it feels like rush that's what i
feel right now it feels like there's a
rush in a way i think it's just that we
have a lot of people who
were members in the past and moved to
fresno and we we think it'd be an easy
entry to the market and so we you kind
of feel like
no this thing is easy we got three other
gyms only making 30 grand a year you're
going to put your attention there and
those just go flat and then all of a
sudden you're now at four locations you
make no profit
and then you're like [ __ ]
when you were had when you had one
facility just one
way back how much were you making in
profit a month like 40 grand
so you make less money now and you got
more locations
yeah but we had kind of
the
at the time we were able to
there was three owners and all three of
us worked there and we had the small
group and we had the personal training
and in a way we had created the system
that you guys have now but
unintentionally and we just didn't even
really realize it and now that we see it
we're like oh [ __ ] that's why we made so
much more money
so
uh we're getting back to you know our
roots and trying to figure out how to
implement it on a larger scale now and
so that way you know once we do make it
really profitable again then we have
everything ready to roll for the next
one so i would say one just final piece
on this is just
make it super profitable because of
pride you have in doing a good job
not so that
you can do x y and z because then it
makes x y and z the goal rather than the
work
if you make your intention to build the
best [ __ ] gym out there not so that
you can but just because it is what you
take pride in
you'll have what you want but it takes a
big shift like i could just you know and
if you'd asked me the franchise question
originally like i could just say like
yeah man like it's fine you got three
out of fourth location and then you know
talk to this guy and he'll set you up
with franchising but like you wouldn't
be successful not with the perspective
that you have right now not with the
unit economics if and i know this is
probably not you know as fun on a group
call but i'm just being real with you
like if you really want to do this and
you really want to do this
fix the gym
hardcore my feelings don't get hurt man
i appreciate it
i said it would love it it's absolutely
desired for you to [ __ ] crush it
action steps
take a hard look at the other two
locations i would consider consolidating
one if you can look at when the other
leases are up and then go back to making
forty thousand dollars a month and then
slowly
slowly
it might take a year it might take two
years for you to get to that to keep
forty thousand dollars a month without
you being there at all
once you do that
then you can have the discussion of
whatever else you want to do and if that
sounds like man that's going to take
time
first point i said you're in a rush
appreciate it
mutual man thanks for thanks for
speaking out